[Music]  did Nicki Minaj just say that she's  dating Eminem's the rapper posted this  Instagram video late Thursday night and  when a fan asked if she was dating  Eminem she replied quote yes it's  possible she's joking since the song in  the video makes a reference to Slim  Shady himself Eminem also responded  quote girl you know it's true nikki is  single though she split from nas in  December and she and Eminem go way back  she presented him with the best rap  album award at the Grammys in 2011 and  they teamed up on the song Romans  revenge in 2010 earlier this week nikki  pushed back her album queen release date  from june to august and earlier this  month she told 80 to expect at least one  collab on the album which we're thinking  now could maybe be eminem many  collaborations or duets trios et has  reached out to reps for both nikki and  eminem  [Music]